[Music]
moving on
our main story tonight concerns i'm
sorry to say tucker carlson a man who
gives tuckers an even worse name than
they already have
this week as he now seems to every week
tucker set off a bit of a firestorm
so we've got new hairstyles and
maternity flight suits pregnant women
are going to fight our wars
it's a mockery of the us military well
china's military becomes more masculine
as it's assembled the world's largest
navy
our military needs to become as joe
biden says more feminine whatever
feminine means anymore
since men and women no longer exist what
are you talking about you performatively
outraged wedge salad
now he's packed a lot in there from
transphobia to weirdly extolling the
masculinity of china's navy to his
completely misplaced outrage at joe
biden over those flight suits which were
part of an initiative that started when
trump was president and also
included ensuring that body armor
actually fits women service members
which is obviously a good idea those
comments sparked an
all too familiar cycle of condemnation
defensiveness and hype and it seems
like every week now tucker has another
one of these many controversies
last week it was the dr seuss
and look i would like nothing more
than to not play into his wildly
offensive stick you might even be
thinking right now
why give him the attention that he's so
clearly trolling for but the fact is
we're not giving tucker any attention
he's not already getting a lot of
the night he made those flight suit
remarks he was the most watched show
on cable he averages over three million
views a night
and does well in the key 25 to 54 demo
meaning that young people are watching
him
as well as the normal fox audience of
retirees and their sad imprisoned pets
he is so important to the network that
they are expanding tucker's presence
launching a new video podcast and
long-form documentary series and if that
wasn't enough
tucker's also been floated as a
potential future presidential candidate
which should be seriously alarming
because of all the things that tucker is
a conspiracy theorist a misogynist
islamophobe a troll
one of the most dangerous is that he is
the most prominent vessel in america
for white supremacist talking points and
i already know what tucker will say
about this because
whenever this topic comes up he has the
exact same reaction
what does that even mean white
nationalism
let's be literal for a minute what is
that exactly
i don't even know what white nationalism
means and i'm not going gonna get on
that rabbit hole with you now
why doesn't anyone ever define white
supreme what is white supremacy can
somebody tell us in very clear language
what a white supremacist
is okay first very clear language seems
like a high bar to clear for a man who
spends 85 percent of his time making the
befuddled face of a 13th century farmer
learning about bitcoin
and i promise that we we're actually
going to give tucker a pretty clear
definition of white supremacy later in
this piece
and he does seem to need one because
whenever he tries to define it himself
it tends to be self-servingly narrow
this show was not on the air for six
months before there was an organized and
highly aggressive campaign
by prominent democrats to denounce us as
white supremacists
the first time it happened the people
who work on this show many of them kids
were shocked and horrified by that white
supremacists
what's worse than that the phrase evokes
images of
burning crosses and lynchings it's awful
okay
first i'm so sorry tucker i honestly
didn't realize that your show was
staffed entirely by children
i certainly never intended for them to
get caught up in all of this so my
sincere apologies you tiny little
rascals
but i don't burn crosses or lynch people
so i can't be a white supremacist
is a pretty weak argument he's like
saying i can't be an anti-semite because
i didn't do the holocaust or
i can't be a sexual predator because i
didn't produce good will hunting
there is more than one way to be a
terrible person
and tucker conveniently for him doesn't
fit neatly into a lot of people's
perception of
white supremacists especially if they
share his definition that it must
require
burning crosses clan hoods and a name
tag that says hello my name is a racist
you might even have friends who think
tucker can't be racist i've never heard
him say the n word as if that is the
bar
but for the record white supremacists
themselves
seem to be big fans of what tucker's
been doing just listen to derek black
a former white supremacist whose father
started stormfront
the largest oldest white supremacist
site on the internet
talk about just how much his family
likes tucker's show
my family watches tucker carlson show
once and then watches it on the replay
because they feel that he is making the
white nationalist talking points
better than they have and they're trying
to get some tips
on how to how to advance it yeah they
watch it want to enjoy it and a second
time to learn from it
they watch tucker the same way i watch
the drew barrymore show first time for
fun second to figure out how she can
possibly successfully pull off a segment
in which a child makes a shirley temple
while stanley tucci quietly drinks an
entire glass of wine on a screen in the
background i don't know how you work
your magic drew
but i want to learn you're advancing
this form
so given that tucker has the admiration
of white supremacists and
the era of millions of your relatives
co-workers and elected officials
we thought tonight it would be worth
talking about him where he came from
what his tactics are and why what he
represents is so dangerous let's start
with some backstory tucker grew up in la
jolla california where his dad
married an heiress to the swanson tv
dinner fortune which is already
interesting because
if tucker's got sad 70s single man
frozen food money that means he's been
doing groundbreaking shows like
cuck-holding is when a humiliating man
watches his wife have an affair
for the love of the game now to hear
tucker tell it he grew up in a simpler
better time he once wishfully claimed
racial solidarity wasn't a working
concept in my southern california
hometown
most people barely had last names much
less ethnic identities which is a pretty
weird thing to say
if your full name is tucker swanson
mcnair carlson
and your ethnic identity can best be
described as my brother's name
is buckley swanson peck carlson the only
way he could get any
more ethnically white is if he
mayonnaise
now as a child tucker was sent to
boarding school where he promptly did
two things
fail to impress any number of
prestigious universities and
start dating the headmaster's daughter a
headmaster who in return
arranged to get him into trinity college
he then became a print journalist
reportedly after his father told him
that journalism
will take anybody which to his dad's
credit did kind of turn out to be true
tucker's lead to tv though came as an
accident supposedly
back in the 90s dan rather show called
the magazine where tucker was working
looking for somebody to talk about the
oj trial and the receptionist there told
him
everyone else is still at lunch can you
do it which might be
the single whitest origin story i have
ever heard
hey you yeah you with the skin and face
we've got an extra career lying around
are you interested but despite his total
lack of preparation tucker was almost
immediately hitting on themes that he'd
be echoing for the next
25 years because here is one of his very
first tv appearances in the aftermath of
the o.j verdict
let me ask you mr carlson do you think
we're honest with each other race to
race oh no of course not
i mean you know everybody is terrified
of uh
of one thing you know whites are of
course terrified of being called a
racist blacks are
uh terrified of being belittled of
course i i think we need
actually probably less conversation
about race i think it might do as good
were we to ignore the subject a little
bit and treat each other
as if there were no color boundary
separating us i think that might be
helpful i think we talk about it
in some ways too much okay
first i'm pretty sure that black people
are less terrified of being belittled
than have been killed
jailed economically exploited or indeed
denied access to health care after their
heads
literally explode from hearing someone
in a bowtie and plaid blazer
suggest being called racist is as bad as
actually experiencing racism although
i do want to quickly come back to that
specific bow tie because look
i'm not knocking bow ties in general
they're perfectly fine for a child
attending his first communion or a
hannah barbera animator who can't draw
necks but that bow tie
is too small either commit to it or
don't tucker
don't just put on a tiny bow tie and
hope that no one notices
now from there tucker bounced around a
bit with cancelled chills on both cnn
and msnbc although
in his time at cnn he did manage to
produce and i don't say this lightly
the most 2003 clip of all time you work
with pepsi for a long time
candidly just between you and me how
much pepsi do you think you drink on an
average day
i really do like pepsi really what's
your favorite okay my favorite kind of
pepsi pepsi's pepsi
well you don't drink diet pepsi or no
just just just just
regular pepsi look i cannot stress this
enough
leave britney alone don't do gotcha
journalism about her pepsi consumption
not only has she been through a lot
she's a stone cold legend
she's the definitional diva of the 2000s
and i guarantee you there is not a human
being on earth who doesn't perk up when
that violin hook from toxic comes on
exactly put some respect
on her name tucker and of course
hashtag free brittany and while tucker
eventually fell upwards into a primetime
fox show in 2016. the fascinating thing
is
if you go back and watch his early
eclipse you can see him learning the
tricks of his trade
right in front of you what'd you talk
about pat buchanan the republican
firebrand and noted anti-immigrant
crusader
and break down one of buchanan's go-to
moves with the precision of a dedicated
student
i mean pat does raise issues that i
think
are important unfortunately pat buchanan
raises them in a way that
i think is discredited and when it's
hacked he can always fall back on the
line well the you know the tiny cabal
that controls american politics doesn't
like me because i speak truth to power
this is
actually incidentally almost verbatim
what he said the other day
that i offend the plutocracy um that i'm
a wanted man by the inside the beltway
people and in
in every sense cast himself as a as a
victim
who is sort of a karen silkwood of
politics someone who's uh
so truthful that he's being hunted down
by the
uh by the conspiracy that runs
washington i mean it's all a bit much
yeah you're right tucker it is and that
is actually a
pretty salient point there it's just
incredibly hard to take
given who's making it in the same way
it'd be hard to listen to a lecture on
gun safety and overall life choices
from takashi 69 i don't care how good
your advice is
i'm not taking it from you because the
tiny cabal that controls american
politics
doesn't like me because i speak truth to
power is now tucker's signature move he
does it
all the time whenever he's criticized a
few years ago he lost advertisers after
saying and i quote
the immigrants make our country poorer
and dirtier
and more divided and this is how he
fired back
those who won't shut up get silenced
you've seen it a million times it
happens all the time
the enforcers scream racist on twitter
until everybody gets intimidated
it's a tactic a well-worn one nobody
thinks it's real
and it won't work with this show we're
not intimidated
we plan to try to say what's true until
the last day and the truth is
unregulated mass immigration has badly
hurt this country's natural landscape
oh off tucker you relentlessly
indignant picket fence
how did you go from criticizing pat
buchanan for that precise tactic
to basically imitating him it's all to
borrow a phrase a bit
much but that technique gets to the
absolute heart of tucker's show so often
he positions himself as someone just
asking the hard questions the ones that
they don't want you asking questions
like is affirmative action racist and
should america be selective with
immigrants and has the democratic party
become anti-white and anti-male
just asking questions while heavily
implying that the answer to those
questions
is yes but when in turn anyone questions
him they are not just censoring free
speech they are launching an attack
on the foundations of our democracy and
the vast working class who this
humble tv dinner princeling somehow
represents
and the most telling thing about
tucker's framing off himself as the
scourge of the elites and the
hero of the common man is that for
tucker who constitutes
the common man is very selective take
ilhan omar just watch him lose his
over a clip that he's about to play of
something she said if
anyone should love america it's ilhan
omar this country rescued her from a
squalid kenyan refugee camp and made her
a national figure quite an ascent
but ilhon amar is not grateful she hates
us for it
watch omar tell us it is time to
dismantle our country
as long as our economy and political
systems
prioritize profit without considering
who is profiting who is being shut out
we will perpetuate this inequality
so we cannot stop at criminal justice
system
we must begin the work of dismantling
the whole system of oppression
wherever we find it
dismantle the american economy and the
american system of government
institutions that generations of
americans built
over hundreds of years all right there
is already enough there in the
sneering condescension that ilhan omar
should be quietly grateful her entire
life because she was granted asylum when
she was a child but
let's just consider the vast distance
between what you just heard her say
and what he seemed to hear because
according to tucker dismantling the
system of oppression
means dismantling the entire american
economy and system of government now
did he inadvertently make a nuanced
point about how systemic oppression is
definitionally baked into every level
and facet of that very same system yeah
yes he did am i going to give him credit
for doing that no
especially not when this is what he said
next the problem is
there are many of us here who do like
this country
we live here we don't want to destroy it
we have every right to fight to preserve
our nation and our heritage and our
culture wow
preserve our heritage and culture that
is direct
in fact his pre-written caption there we
have to fight to preserve our nation and
heritage
through a lot of comparisons to the 14
words the
famous white supremacist slogan that
says we must secure the existence of our
people
and a future for white children and when
you put the two together
there is you know a slight similarity
there
i'm just saying if you typed tucker's
quote into a blank word document
nine times out of ten clippy's gonna ask
are you trying to recite the 14 words
now of course clippy has been asking
that a lot more ever since he started
spending so much time on youtube
careful how much time you spend on their
clippy it's turning you into an
and if you think well come on
that seems like a bit of a stretch you
can't know
what tucker means by our heritage and
culture you should know that he hasn't
always been that disciplined
about his messaging in the late 2000s he
used to call into a radio show hosted by
shock jock
bubba the love sponge and in those calls
the thin
veil covering his racism would
occasionally get thrown off in moments
like this a rock is a crappy place
filled with a bunch of
you know semi-literate primitive monkeys
but i just have zero
sympathy for them or their culture a
culture where people just don't use
toilet paper or forks
okay that isn't just incredibly
offensive
it's also the kind of fact-free cultural
hot take that is the essential tucker
carlson experience because
while it is clearly by no means the most
important thing there
for the record table forks were
apparently first used in the middle east
and byzantine empire and were still
conspicuously absent in europe until
centuries later in fact
when the niece of a byzantine emperor
brought a case of forks to venice for
her wedding feast in the 11th century
she was
roundly condemned by the local clergy
for her decadence with one saying
god in his wisdom has provided man with
natural forks his fingers
therefore it is an insult to him to
substitute artificial metal forks for
them
when eating which is absolutely
fascinating because it's not just a
full refutation of tucker's lazy racism
it's also a very fun fork fact
facts are fun the point is
when you know how tucker speaks when he
speaks freely
the filter through which he processes
the world for his audience becomes
painfully apparent because he is smart
enough not to openly say into a camera
that certain races are more deserving of
scorn or
less worthy of respect he will just
heavily imply that
depending on who he's talking about take
the capital riots
tucker said that he deplored the
violence but repeatedly compelled his
viewers
to try and understand where the
demonstrators were coming from
on january 6 we had a riot at the u.s
capitol why did that happen
it happened because millions of american
voters were convinced that the last
election was not fair
where did they get that idea well it
wasn't simply because the last president
told them so you're hearing that now
as if they're animals who take commands
and do what they're told but they're not
animals
they're people they're american citizens
who can see what's happening and come to
their own conclusions about it
they saw the radical increase in mail-in
voting
millions did and it corroded their faith
and the public's faith
in our systems of election okay hold on
people didn't think the election was
rigged because they saw an increase in
mail in voting
they thought that because people like
you repeatedly told them the election
was rigged
and that plea for understanding there is
especially hard to take
when you contrast it with how he reacted
to last summer's black lives matter
protests
people like this don't bother to work
they don't volunteer
or pay taxes to help other people they
live
for themselves they do exactly what they
feel like
doing they say exactly what they feel
like saying
they spray paint their opinions on
buildings
on television hour by hour we watch
these people criminal mobs destroy what
the rest of us
have built they have no right to do that
they don't contribute to the common good
they never have
yet suddenly they seem to have all the
power well
that's quite a different tone and it is
interesting to see who gets to be
american citizens who came to their own
conclusions and who gets to be
criminal mobs who destroy what the rest
of us have built
and it does seem like the dividing line
for tucker on that question is
how easily can you sunburn and look my
point here
isn't that tucker is inconsistent in
addressing two violent protests in
vastly different ways is that he's
actually incredibly consistent because
in both instances
his clear takeaway is that white people
should be terrified of the idea
of any situation where they aren't in
power the main narrative of tucker show
is that power is being taken away from
you his viewer
and that this needs to be resisted he's
run segments just asking questions
remember
like how exactly is diversity our
strength and has argued
not just that it isn't but that it's a
threat to our existence
as a cohesive country in fact he'll
often call to resist that threat
with an interesting choice of phrase
western civilization
is our birthright it makes all good
things
possible undefended it collapses and so
we've got to fight to preserve it
it's a war with one side trying to erase
all remnants of its opponent
in this case western civilization is the
culture into which they're coming
the western civilization we're talking
about superior
to the culture that these immigrants are
bringing do you think it's possible to
move a large
muslim population into the west and
successfully integrate them into western
culture have you seen that anywhere
yeah for tucker it seems western
civilization is somehow both the mighty
and essential bedrock upon which all
modern human existence is built and also
a delicate house of cards that will
collapse if you so much as look at it
wrong
and again he will be careful not to
verbally link
race and civilization like he's calling
into a love sponge's radio show in 2006
but he will occasionally dance
incredibly close to it
let me just stipulate i'm for getting
along i'm for color blindness i'm for
tolerance
100 but i also think that if things
radically change in your country it's
okay for you to say what is this
and maybe i don't want to live in a
country looks nothing like the country i
grew up in
is that bigoted uh yeah
yeah it is that's like saying i've got
ten fingers and toes a pointy face with
a little pink rosebud mouth a cat sized
body a long weird tail and i eat garbage
does that make me a possum
yes yes it does that's the literal
definition
of the thing you just described and that
is the whole thing with tucker he might
not say
black or white he'll insist that he's
for color blindness
he'll build in deniability by phrasing
things as a question like
what does racism look like what kind of
embodying the answer
but when you put all of this together
the pattern is clear
he is scared of a country that looks
nothing like the one he grew up in
because diversity isn't our strength
immigrants make our country
poorer dirtier and more divided and any
attempt to change that culture
is an attack on western civilization all
of which is really just a long way of
saying that when tucker asks
what is white supremacy the answer is
basically
that it's a belief that in a country
where white people are dominant
that's all down to their natural and
innate abilities
and any effort to change that is an
affront to the natural order of things
so it's frankly no wonder that that
guy's family
watches tucker twice a night of course
tucker has been endorsed
by white supremacists james alsup a
far-right activist who marched in
charlottesville
once said this to a conference room full
of fellow white supremacists
an example of someone engaging in very
effective rhetoric is of course
tucker carlson tucker is helping
mainstream conservatives change the way
they think about politics and
causing a massive swath of trump voters
to look deeper into many of the issues
that
we already talk about the left is aware
of what he's doing and
he's aware of what he's doing so it
works phenomenally
oh that might be the single worst laugh
i have ever heard and i say that as
someone who has almost forgotten what
human laughter sounds like i've been
stuck inside casper's
for 12 long months now i'm so desperate
to hear the response
of a live audience but if it is a
neo-nazi chuckle ping-ponging off the
walls of a hotel ballroom
i think i might be out and look if
everything i've shown you tonight
somehow still isn't enough
let's hear from a literal former grand
wizard of white supremacist
david duke he's not only tweeted
approvingly about tucker in the past
saying
tucker is right and can't cuck the tuck
which as
all tucker viewers know refers to when a
humiliated man watches his wife have an
affair
duke even has a podcast where he
sometimes just recaps tucker's segments
from the night before
last year when endorsing trump for
president duke even suggested that
tucker carlson should be his vp
explaining tucker's value to the white
supremacist cause like this
he doesn't use the word white very often
but that's the underlying message that
he's he's showing and he shows that
there is massive racism in america
against white people
while at the same time saying there's no
systematic racism
but people get the message yeah people
do get the message although to be fair
it's not like it's written in a complex
code it's a walking yacht club
scrunching his face up for an hour every
night and saying to a conservative
audience
they are coming for you in modulating
tongues we're not exactly in riddle of
the sphinx territory here
and all of this is why as tempting as it
is to dismiss the controversy that
follows tucker every week as
one more artifact of our outrage culture
it's important to remember
that what tucker is saying is
outrageous
because no one in their right mind would
sit down
pop in their headphones fire up david
duke's podcast and think hey
i'm not a white supremacist but
millions of people watch tucker on tv
every night
spouting well-laundered versions of
pretty much the same talking points
and there is real harm in that because
while white supremacy is clearly
dangerous when
promoted by self-avowed white
supremacists it can actually be even
more dangerous when it isn't
and what tucker carlson show sells in
addition to utterly
terrible pillows is very seductive
it's the idea that this country is
fundamentally colorblind that anyone who
mentions race is just trying to start
trouble
that historic oppression is no longer
relevant and that in fact you
his viewers are the ones currently being
oppressed
and if he can sell his audience on his
white identity politics if he can
persuade them
that the big existential threat to
america right now is diversity
it sort of doesn't matter if he says
allowed what his preferred solutions to
that might be
and while it's bad enough to hear that
white supremacist families
gather around to watch tucker twice the
fact is
millions of viewers a night watch him
once and once
is already more than enough
you